and finally new rule here on Valentine's
night every couple must ask themselves
do you have an unhealthy relationship
with technology when you wake up do you
turn towards your partner or do you pick
up your phone I keep reading about these
people who identify as didja sexuals or
robosexuals people who prefer prefer to
have relationships with even have sex
with their phone or a robot or a doll
and I know where this is going because
everything that happens in life happens
in movies first ex machina Lars and the
real girl AI West world Blade Runner
2049 her all of them featuring hookups
that violate my number-one rule in
relationships never make love to someone
you have to unplug to clean
let's look at the disturbing trend on
this chart from the beginning of time to
1937 there were zero instances of any
kind of hanky-panky with machines then
came the first in-home washing machines
followed by the first housewives sitting
on them men in 1968 the Hitachi Magic
Wand made men obsolete in 1998 the first
webcam girls allowed interpersonal
relationships to happen in real time
through your computer 2007 a new product
called the iPhone makes sexting tinder
and dick pics mainstream 2018 real doll
X comes on the market huh
gone are the days when having a sex doll
meant you'd [ __ ] an air mattress with
Rouge on it
[Applause]
now now they look like this yeah you
thought about it didn't you and not only
is this doll made from high-end silicone
and sculpted to perfection like the Real
Housewives but she's actually part robot
now so she can simulate orgasms just
like
that one and this stuff isn't just for
men anymore by the way they're working
on a male companion they're working on a
male companion to the female robot shown
here no wait no here that's not it this
this is it this is Henry a male sex pod
with a huge Bionic dick that ejaculates
face moisturizer from Sephora how are we
supposed to how are we supposed to
compete with that and this is not just a
passing fad like fidgets spinners or the
rule of law a guy in China couldn't find
a wife so he built one it can only speak
a few words but he says he has plans for
improving it by making it speak even for
[Applause]
he said in France there's a woman with a
similar story who says she isn't
attracted to human men only male robots
she shoot so she made one with her 3d
printer and now they're engaged
she says she simply dislikes physical
contact with human flesh well you know
there's an app for kissing your phone
now but no tongue
that would be weird this German woman
claims she's erotic Lee in love with the
Boeing 737 Hey look planes are sexy I
can see falling in love with one but a
Boeing that's not safe there's a guy in
Japan who married a hologram which is
great unless the electricity goes out
and he says to judge him by human
standards his quote simply not right he
says it's as if you were trying to talk
a gay man into dating a woman this is a
movement now they're here they've got
gears get used to it this is the latest
emerging sexual orientation demanding
equality people who don't need people
and feel that makes them the luckiest
people in the world
[Laughter]
but but has no-one noticed that in all
the movies where human machine
interaction takes place it never ends
well for the humans sure at first the
sex is great but then they turn on you
and if I wanted to get [ __ ] by a nap
I'd caucus in Iowa
it is a dangerous trend for men and
women to be finding ways to get along
without each other human to human
romance sex love it's the last bond
holding us together
really politics is gone a common culture
is gone we need to keep [ __ ] and that
is my message to you on this Valentine's
night find someone you love
[Music]
you